how cool is this damn Arab [ __ ] yeah
that's where you realize we're all human
it's weird when you realize we all like
[ __ ] TV we all like human excellence
and that song is like how we all react
all of us and they're all they're all
basically we're all the same it's
[ __ ] beautiful
all right one love everybody one love
Philippine I stop that - stop that
chicken hey hey hey don't ever don't ah
don't ever no one love - the voice one
love and be dead serious
I've got I will quit this show right now
if you ever add or do that no no I'm not
saying that say like no hey let's not do
that
I'm saying if you ever get serious again
we're watching the voice and go one love
- no no this all I'm saying love it no
no that's how I'm saying this I just
want to say this and don't what was
weird what you well watch my words you
don't be revered none of that again no I
go we're in the middle of listen people
see you know one love no no I did this
is all I wanted to say I know what you
know what you're hanging out with the
wrong people
no no I haven't seen you a while people
maybe I misspoke this is all I'm trying
to say and don't and this is all I'm
trying to say and I get I get that I'm
trying to say that what now we'll be
careful cuz I will walk off I don't know
now hold on that easy man no I don't
need tools I know I'm just only tools
just exhale no don't need you be all
right let me express myself I just
wanted to say this Captain Planet I want
to say this about it about the voice be
my 51 year old gay for all right and I
mean this and I this is no big deal I
just want to say they'll big deal when I
see the voice like that I just want to
say I'm saying will redeem yourself here
I truly in my heart deep down okay
a true little here because you didn't
you know Lou tell you about - no I'm not
I'm not gonna tear up I'm just gonna say
that I mean this how you're half mass in
your pants no and I did everybody
listening every one of you whether
you're in jail wherever you are
no ideas no sir I love you as much as I
love my own mother
is that what you meant by one love one
love everybody what did you do that I
got to go one by one love it I saw the
arrow people say boys Filipino people
thinking I was like we're all we all
react the same the music and I was like
and chin is Korean in a stinks country
and the point is that it brings you all
over [ __ ] I feel sick
all I need that I wear like this no no
all I mean is we share this we share the
same cuz I know you too well and then
when you got sir said one love now I
just feel sick I just mean we all share
the same heart there's a lot more love
in this world I'm just saying we all
share the same you know hearts are
connected with an invisible line called
the voice that's all I'm saying voice
changing lies meant it's always right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]